two guards accused of not checking on
Jeffrey Epstein the day he died in New
York have pleaded not guilty to charges
of falsifying records and conspiracy
they allegedly did not check on him for
about eight hours mullah legi is outside
the Manhattan Correctional Facility
where Epstein died mola
why such serious charges well good
morning Anthony no Jeffrey Epstein was
kept at the special housing unit here at
the MCC where guards were supposed to
check on him every 30 minutes
prosecutors say that didn't happen but
one of EPs teens criminal defense
attorneys as well as the union that
represents these correctional officers
argue that these guards are being made
scapegoats according to a federal
indictment correctional officer Tobin
Noel logged more than 75 inmate counts
the day Jeffrey Epstein died but
evidence allegedly shows that she and
fellow officer Michael Thomas did not
perform any of their required rounds
Thomas's attorney blames systemic
failures in the Bureau of Prisons we
believe that when all the evidence is
presented about how the system was ran
maybe you'll have a different
appreciation for what was going on
Epstein was found unresponsive in his
cell with a noose around his neck around
6:30 a.m. on August 10th
he'd attempted suicide just weeks
earlier we take every inmates life very
seriously in the Bureau of Prisons on
Capitol Hill Tuesday senators grilled
the Bureau of Prisons director about the
failure to protect Epstein there's got
to be their major malfunction of the
system or criminal enterprise at foot to
allow this to happen so are you looking
at both is the FBI looking at both if
the FBI is involved then they are
looking at criminal enterprise yes
surveillance video allegedly shows that
aside from Noel Thomas and two other
officers at the facility no one entered
the section where Epstein was held
during that shift prosecutors say in the
hours before
Epstein's body was discovered the
officers were seen sitting in a common
area approximately 15 feet from his cell
the indictment claims they spent that
time surfing the internet and for about
two hours both appeared to have been
asleep CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clayman the purpose of those tapes
is to put an end to conspiracy theories
and show that no one else had access to
Jeffrey Epstein at the time of his death
both guards are now out on $100,000 bond
Thomas's attorney says they are looking
forward to their day in court hoping for
a positive resolution both guards are
expected back in court next Monday Tony
and we'll be watching more thank you
very much